but we begin with correspondent Phil
Keating back again at the shooting scene
in parkland Florida good ena film
good evening Bret the accused highschool
killer at this high school behind me
described as calm and cool by the
Broward County Sheriff just in the past
40 minutes updating the timeline of 20
19 year old Nicholas Cruz's alleged
timeline of Terror 221 p.m. yesterday he
starts shooting inside those hallways
and classrooms hitting four classrooms
and hit wounding or killing students and
teachers on two floors he then flees on
foot blending in with the crowd gets to
a nearby Walmart bought a soda then
meanders over to a nearby McDonald's and
actually sits down for a time before
deciding to go ahead and keep on walking
and was only then shortly thereafter he
was detained and arrested thanks to
great police work that caught up with
him are you Nicolas Jacob Cruz 19 year
old Nicholas Cruz five foot seven and a
hundred and thirty-one pounds faced a
florida magistrate this afternoon 24
hours after allegedly shooting and
killing 17 boys girls and faculty at the
high school that expelled him last year
Cruz is charged with 17 counts of
premeditated murder and will remain held
in Broward County custody are you gonna
be held no bond unlike other mass
shooters who took their own lives
investigators say Cruz tried to escape
putting down his assault rifle and
blending in with fleeing students from
Marjorie Stoneman Douglas High School
inside the high school heavily armed
SWAT teams police and deputies cleared
out each classroom one by one rescuing
terrified students and teachers who had
variegated themselves and hidden clauses
today's not any easier than yesterday
was all the victims families have been
notified Thursday morning's update the
FBI confirmed it had been alerted to the
suspect four months ago from this
YouTube poster who claimed someone with
the same name as the suspect said quote
I'm going to be a professional school
shooter I knew that I couldn't just
ignore that so a screenshot of the
comment I sent it to the appropriate
authorities the FBI conducted database
reviews checks but was then was unable
to further identify the person who
actually made the comment worst high
school shooting in US history
exceeding Columbine by two fatalities
began around 2:30 as school was starting
to let out when according to the school
superintendent the suspect arrived in an
uber according to investigators he then
shot and killed three people outside
then went inside pulled a fire alarm and
while wearing a gas mask and carrying
multiple magazines as well as smoke
grenades started shooting at students
and teachers as they flooded into the
hallway he then fled an assisting
Coconut Creek Florida police officer
spotted the suspect in a neighborhood
about a mile away and arrested him I
pulled my vehicle over immediately
engage the subject
he complied with my commands we offer
these words Oh God
students and families gathering today
outside the school grounds tributes and
mementos for the victims on the fence
outside the police line now hangs 17
crosses one cross per victim placed
there by chaplain Robert Osler of the
city of Cape Coral they were worried
about a pimple someone comes in and
starts shooting they shouldn't have to
worry about being in a war zone and not
too far from the high school where we
are right now a vigil has now begun at
the city of parkland amphitheater it's
an open-air park we're expecting many
hundreds if not thousands of people to
attend to pay homage and commemorate the
lives of those 17 people killed at this
high school yesterday and of course
express condolences and grief to their
families who have had their families
absolutely crushed and destroyed it
remains a very complex and active
humongous crime scene investigation more
than 2,000 people have been interviewed
so far more will follow
also the investigators are still
analyzing the school's surveillance
camera videotape trying to even better
piece together the alleged gunman
timeline for example why we're only
those cific four classrooms picked
that's still we don't know
Brett Phil Keating live in parkland Phil
thank you